so there's a pretty good chance that I'm
about to ruin Dragon Ball Z's English
dub for you so uh yeah I'm sorry you
will never be able to unsee this so back
in the day when Funimation
animations might get bored and stop
watching during these trademark Dragon
Ball stare Downs so in addition to
replacing the soundtrack they also added
a lot of additional dialogue to fill up
the silence but it's kind of hard to add
dialogue to a show that has already been
animated can't exactly invent mouth
flaps TFS style so what did FUNimation
do well they would just have the added
dialogue be spoken from characters off
screen and as soon as you notice this
it's almost comedic how often it happens
uh
you fooling what
are they dearly for this so yeah next
time you watch Dragon Ball Z in English
watch just how often this sort of thing
happens know that you're aware of it if
you're like me it will haunt you for the
rest of your life